you know I've been meaning to tell you
this for a while but I I probably about
15 years
but uh you know I
I feel like I've seen you all my life
and here you are in person you look so
great would you bite me in the neck oh
my gosh
we're out of time that's it yeah yeah
why does it go by so fast
if I could tell you the amount of time
women have said that to me
[Music]
excuse my appearance I mean I know you
have a lot of experience with guns so I
decided to put mine out
you're very very cute you know this
right do you have a boyfriend
[Applause]
he's right like I deserve you
maybe you do deserve me maybe you do I
feel like you might deserve me for a
couple of minutes
[Applause]
happened hold on I'm getting red
how was the transformation because
killmonger looks stupid are you touching
yours no I thought I dropped something
off there but it was I got a hole in the
shirt no no no no no no
um yeah new shirt
um I'm looking at your shirt it's a nice
shirt my eyes are up here appreciate it
sorry it's all good someone tweeted you
uh this question if you could have kids
with any celebs oh no
it would have been you it's not you
it's not
listen end of the day this is what makes
me baby end of the day this is what
makes no no
you got different types of men you got
soldiers and you got tanks
I'm the one that's shooting the bullet
you understand what I'm saying so
basically you know to get to what I got
you got to think about a squirrel if he
goes up a tree what happens you Dad
going right Peter Pan Is Gonna Come
I'm so happy to be back you know you
were my first ever
yes that too I suppose
um like you know take it from here uh I
think the really the the this is a
superhero film we've all seen a bunch of
superhero films and they tend to be
complicated
damaged people that are dealing with
milia Clark did you get to chat with
everyone backstage
um yeah kind of did you get to talk to
him yeah
Emilia Clarke
actually blushing
um yeah I just think you're Wicked
thank you look at those boots yes I know
it's so weird I almost wore those it was
really embarrassing because one of us
would have had to go home
sorry yeah you're good hey you are
pretty cute I just wanna try that
it's actually is
clearly you don't read your fan mail
I can't find me I sent you
I sent you a card and when I told your
assistant that I loved your book she was
like you read his book
he doesn't even read his fan mail yeah
no I I swear I didn't I didn't get a
card I wrote you a card I never got a
response and I was very heartbroken well
I I I I I apologize right now because
I'm looking for I just wanted an apology
that's all I wanted you have the
unreserve it thank you oh no absolutely
thank you take your dress off
[Applause]
do you guys have matching nail polish
yeah I tried wow I got them done
yesterday after seeing her fingernails
but I don't have as long nail beds as
she does okay stop you're working now
but yeah yeah but you have long
beautiful hair and you're perfect you're
perfect you are I love you I love you
too I mean I'd spend a million dollars
if I were you on security I don't need
it these guys are soft
that's why you know and what's the
opposite of soft heart
foreign
I do have one slight request from you
though
um so would you would you be able to ask
me how I'm doing oh
you can say no everyone will hate you
but you can say no no
yes uh well since I you know haven't
been up up to speed on the show thank
you yeah how are you doing yeah
what's your best your best quality
that's that's hard you have so many
great qualities
yours is that you're super pretty wow no
no yours is your kindness I'd say is
your best quality you're a very kind
person I would say yours is your
selflessness you're always thinking
about others okay okay and she's pretty
and you're pretty you know in this
picture Chris is holding a Honeycrisp
apple
oh shoot
wait what am I looking at
how do you like them apples
are they true yeah no it's a Macintosh
I got distracted certainly don't know
and I spoke to you last night and you
mentioned that touching Zach's ABS is
like touching an angel yes uh how does
it feel to hear something like that I'd
love your response to that Zach I just
want to clarify
that they asked okay and you know it is
I I have to say you know to everybody I
have never touched a man with as many
abs as yours so it is otherworldly
oh thank you thank you
um that's really sweet yeah
that's yeah
um cool well you are an angel oh thank
you last summer I was on I forgot to
tell you last time I thought everybody
said we had major major chemistry oh
yeah people said people were saying that
you were hitting on me and I said and I
said I said you have a girlfriend
because no disrespect to her but you do
you were hitting on me I would yeah yeah
I thought you were hitting on me no no I
don't need to hit on you okay you were
hitting on it you were throwing your
body at me
and I just want you to know I appreciate
it
I will strap myself down for this
interview yeah okay well don't use the
word strap around me again
anyway Kelly how are you what I'm saying
is you two should did you ever think we
do have chemistry
to have a lot of fun together
[Music]
danger glowing
[Music]
question if you could pay any love
interest from the Marvel Universe for
Spider-Man who would it be I think
Scarlet Witch is pretty hot you know I
think Elizabeth Olsen's super hot and
really nice as well she was really nice
to meet the premiere so yeah probably
probably start the witch yeah you can
you take mine and then I'll get yours
out
[Music]
it's an Affliction here just what you
blew in there you know how to do it
I'm sure you do
apparently not
just blow a little softer more
consistently you'll be fine face to face
chest to chest you could you know smell
each other's breasts breath sorry
oh
a whole bunch of people just got very
happy in the audience
hold the phone
um
I think the walls is very sexy I'll
leave it there it's impossible for me
not to just sit what do breasts smell
like Tom I'm sorry Tom
I couldn't leave that open I apologize
um when I the reason I the way that I
met Simon was they asked me to be a
guest judge Focus Conan to be um
really we'll be real here for a second
you didn't think I was gonna look down
there I think oh
[Applause]
but be like a beautiful kind loving
person who who's fighting for the right
thing always and even has the right the
the ability to be forgiving and move
forward because you are loving character
get massive
I try not to let it go too much
Scarlet's always in superhero shape
don't let her tell you anything
otherwise that black widow suit slips on
and off pretty easily
how about you have you seen the growing
or change of time
no no
grown so much but unfortunately not in
height you put me on the same height
five foot six and a half
anyway sorry don't let them don't let
them try to take you what will you say
um I was just gonna say that you know
you changed but in all the right ways
you know you just grown up and you've
and you've you know you have the
pressure of being Spider-Man in real
life
um and I think you've handled it with a
lot of Grace thank you yeah so you're
not wearing a bra
I love this
really well that's good we're having a
good time already no we are I I'm having
an excellent time although I'm wearing a
bra because but I'm older than you yeah
that's what happens with age I I love
you I've had two children I have had two
children oh they start to you need a
little more help I think mine were doing
that before the kids came along really
why are you rubbing up my chair like
this
is that is is that a bone villain thing
you'd be a good bone villain actually I
think this is you know you so I'm
subliminally maybe doing what I whoa
this might be
oh no he drives me in a bra let me Flex
let me Flex